a
[Música]
i
los casos por kobe 19 continúan
aumentando en nueva york y en algunas
zonas de este estado e incluso se supera
el 3 por ciento de infección algo que
preocupa mucho al gobernador andrew como
porque quedan menos de dos semanas para
que comiencen las celebraciones por
sense given el gobernador andrew cuomo
ha culpado de este aumento de casos a la
fatiga tras meses luchando contra el
coronavirus y a los gimnasios y
restaurantes que desde el pasado viernes
están obligados a cerrar sus puertas a
las diez de la noche aquí en la ciudad
de nueva york el alcalde bill de blasio
ya ha advertido que si el nivel de
contagio supera el 3% ahora mismo
estamos en un 2 57% los colegios
volverán a cerrar sus puertas y en la
enseñanza seguirá de manera remota todo
en un momento en el que eeuu acaba de
superar los 11 millones de contagiados
más de 560.000 de ellos proceden de este
estado del estado de nueva york que
ocupa el cuarto lugar en contagios por
detrás de texas california y florida
[Música]
en la costa oeste los casos de kobe
continúan aumentando de manera
exponencial los gobernadores de
california oregón y washington han hecho
un llamamiento a sus residentes
pidiéndoles que por favor eviten a toda
costa viajar fuera de los estados y del
país si es así si es necesario viajar
por favor piden que se realice una
cuarentena de por lo menos dos semanas
todo para evitar tener que cerrar los
estados ahora mismo también hay
preocupación aquí en california porque
se ha superado ya el millón de casos de
kobe de muchos hospitales se encuentran
ya colapsados de hecho también algunos
condados han decidido prohibir las
reuniones dentro de los establecimientos
para frenar el avance del virus
[Música]
en florida al igual que en el resto de
eeuu continúan sumándose nuevos casos de
coronavirus este domingo se superaron
los 10.000 casos diarios y ya hay casi
900.000 registros de contagios en el
estado desde el inicio de la pandemia la
preocupación de los sanitarios es que
florida se convierta de nuevo en el
epicentro de la pandemia esta cifra es
la más alta desde el 5 de julio y los
hospitales están superando los récords
de ingreso respecto a meses anteriores
lo mismo pasa con la tasa de positividad
que está en su pico si lo comparamos con
los últimos 14 días el sur de la florida
que es el área más poblada de todo el
estado prácticamente registra la mitad
de todos los contagios que se dan en el
estado en las autoridades sanitarias se
están pidiendo a la población extremar
todas las precauciones a pesar de que el
gobernador de florida el republicano ron
de santis eliminó todas las medidas de
prevención y se volvió a la situación de
antes de la pandemia también ha
prohibido multar a las personas que no
llevaban mascarilla en los espacios
públicos pero ahora la amenaza de un
nuevo cierre planea aquí en florida
[Música]